[Music]
you and
I sun and strawberry Sky Run go come we
go build a shrine PSS and song We may
live inside you call I come we go
Carnival like nothing I have seen before
million dream with the story of her and
him never finding love heav was hiding
you I saw desire
you this is a light did you imagine it
heavier is a problem with y'all too y'
skunk always Shen the sack I would
gladly purchase from somewhere else if I
knew would to get
it but you
[Music]
don't about
you I'm about you
[Music]
hello
beautiful what's that sweet Mel huh long
story what's that this is for you to
give to vinia
mother my Ling on
weed it helps with the
glycom better wash before you go see her
I'm just trying to make sure you don't
die a virgin son oh
wow I'm not a
virgin what you do at night behind that
curtain doesn't count
that is not me that's the local Rats the
very loud rats
okay
Mom one day I'm going to get you out of
here put you in a big home where you can
do whatever you want to
do I promise
you
home is where you are happy son and I'm
happy here with
you but the son that's barely able to
provide for you and another who's
running a muck with some false prophet
Thomas is following his purpose we have
but to love him I have but to love
you
son be the body not the the
shadow hold space yeah I
know
hold
space
okay now go wash your stink I don't
stink I do
stink toward oh your and gra I don't
really feel good about this
Elijah Jed killing you we feel worse
stop saying that it is the
truth Elijah and cl two rotten eggs
quiet I'm my
[Music]
way silence is a of me take it slow I'm
on the edge don't push go slow I they
drift don't rush go slow Heaven is
Elemental our souls
transcendental I'm on the edge don't
push go slow I stay a drift don't rush
go slow Heaven is
elevated our souls
[Music]
levitated oh
oh CR de
Clans unto you be peace Jed judging by
your unarranged rifal you most likely
lack my money my horse and my Chariot am
I
correct it's only been a few hours you
said I had 30 days to pay you back mhm
now it's 29 days 22 hours or death both
of you should be aware before I crucify
you I'm I'm going to get a little eil
first isn't the act of crucifixion in
and of itself of evil you know you make
a deal with the
devil it's going to cost you a
second now exit my place of restitution
before I render those 29 days to
zero don't worry
Elijah I have a plan that is exactly
what I'm worried
about get
out where literally on our way out what
do you think we are doing understand
it's redundant the ID
repent for the Kingdom of Heaven is at
hand everyone is
welcome except
you but am I not a child of the Lord you
high fut Nom Pope he want me to baptize
you to attain good favor with our Lord
so that when you are called to help
Heaven you and this bush man will be
welcome with open
arms yes
basically so
Clans you now believe in
Jesus yes
basically
fire you are merely trying to Swindle Me
by pretending you are now righteous to
seem that you have turned into a
believer in the hope that Jedediah the
terrible won't kill
you uhuh news travels fast in Jerusalem
you have 30 days to pay him or he kills
you both okay John you are magical with
this holy water stuff okay I heard that
you baptized Jesus
himself what makes him more worthy than
I
sne stop that you think you won't get
killed because you are baptized you you
are not a
Believer but I like you
l in spite of your selfish ways there's
a beautiful soul in there
somewhere okay if God exists truly dear
Lord save this sinner from himself Clans
is dumb and stupid always selling his
illegalities when he could just as
easily have a regular occupation and now
he's in trou trouble with the village
Terror and he's also in love with said
tera's little sister who he is not in
the slightest bit worthy of I might add
dear Lord he is definitely going to get
killed by jedadiah the terrible so when
you finally meet him Lord which is
soon please let him inside heaven Lord
and
then kick him out so that she shall
forever know what he is missing because
he did not know the depth of his own
idiocy to not
repent amen amen
[Music]
amen see it
amen wash
him wash
him okay stop washing him what you can't
let him
up 10 minutes or two he's washed what
did you say he is not you want me to
come and slap you you slap
him I do not think that the baptism
Works brother it's because it's all
nonsense but hopefully it will provide
some lency with
[Music]
Jedediah hold on to that don't touch
it give me your names and paper of
identification
Clarence
Elijah there has been a theft in the
area and you men fit the description of
the as salent funny my friend and I have
two entirely different
descriptions you calling me a man of
untruth peasant look why don't we settle
this once and forever show us a sketch
of this as
salent
who are you looking for king
T